President Trump is visiting the CDC on
Friday as he urged people to stay calm
as the corona virus continues to spread
my next guest accompanied the president
to the briefing in Atlanta Georgia
congressman Doug Collins is with me he
is also the ranking member of the House
Judiciary Committee congressman it's
good to see you thanks very much for
joining us what did you learn on your
visit with the President to the CDC sir
well what we learned was is the
administration is still on top of this
they're still moving forward and I think
there's some interesting things learned
number one not just heard the governor
of New York talked about everybody being
tested Maria well the CDC made very
clear the other day is everyone who
needs a test has a test to have its idea
that you need to test everybody is it's
not really an applicable situation when
you're trying to make sure that you're
isolating the known cases so that you
can make proper treatment and that was
what was said the other day at this CDC
that everyone who needs it that any
doctor who needs a test can get that
test done and that is good for us to
isolate the cases to make sure that
we're doing the proper response we also
know that more test kits are coming out
and secretary Hayes are stated there
will be a million and more in the next
weeks to come out so those are gonna be
there for everybody that goes forward
and the other thing that I think the
president made it clear and also dr.
Rifkin and the others at the CDC was is
if they have been on this from day one
this was even something that you would
never hear in most of the media was it
there seemed to be this delayed response
even the governor talked about this but
the CDC from the minute they found out
had began the process of working toward
just as they do any natural any
naturally occurring virus like this to
begin the process of working toward it
so I think the the reassurance that the
president was at CDC doing and making
sure the American people knew that we
were on top of this was the biggest
thing coming out of that the other well
I mean that's true but at the same time
I know that the CDC sent out 50 test
kits to 50 states and then said wait you
know don't don't use the tests they're
defective tests so there was there was a
mistake there somehow why send out 50
states to the test kits if they actually
weren't usable and so we don't really
have a clear number on terms of how many
people are sick because we couldn't we
couldn't do the testing right well no I
think that's a there was a mistake sent
out that was corrected very quickly I
think having a clear number of having a
clear number of how many people
the viruses is it ongoing you know I
said that's one of the things that the
CDC has said the administration said
there are some people who actually may
have this virus and get sick but they
don't actually go to the doctor there's
a lot of things in process here that's
why we're making sure that I think the
money that we passed this past week that
the president sign is important because
it allows the states it allows the
beginning to talk about people who need
to be quarantined need to have the
medical treatment to have everything
that they need and we need to make sure
that people do the basic stuff the
Surgeon General's talked about this a
lot have is wash your hands stay out of
crowds if you're sick if you know
there's it's gonna be a problem make
sure that you take the proper
precautions just as you do with every
other thing and I think there's been a
heightened awareness that and I think
you're gonna see these cases contained
and as they do come up as we go forward
we're gonna be able to have a good
response to it because the resources are
already available for that we're gonna
speak with dr. Carson in a moment he's
on the taskforce of course the White
House Task Force and I and I want to ask
him about hospitals and why they're
preparing for millions of people to go
to the hospital millions I mean that's
that's a question for dr. Carson coming
up but let me ask you you congressman
you've got a very important deadline
this upcoming week on March 15th the
FISA surveillance tool certain FISA
surveillance tools will expire do you
have the votes
do you believe to actually expand these
surveillance tools where does this file
a reauthorization go next week well
that's that's a great question you not
been talking about this issue for a long
time the FISA issue is something that we
need to take time now to actually not
only look at these extensions and
remember there's two parts to FISA
there's the actual FISA part that is in
law that's the court that was set up in
the 70s that is in permanent law it
doesn't come up for renewal and then you
have extra parts that came up through
the Patriot Act and others like the lone
wolf provision roving wiretap those
things that do come up in a sunset so we
have to approve those in my position I
think the house is position and I'm sure
the president has mentioned this as well
it's now is our time to actually look at
what needs to happen with the court
itself so that we don't get another
Carter page we don't get another
president why President Trump is a
candidate and as president was attacked
by rogue cabal at the DOJ abusing the
FISA process we've been working on this
for over a year and a half and I think
the house right now isn't in no position
to pass anything that doesn't have some
actual title one
which is the actual court itself so that
we can protect American citizens in
sensitive areas that's being worked on
I've been working on that through the
weekend we're continuing to work on that
I really wish that the Senate over the
past year had they'd been in the
majority hadn't had more hearings and
stuff on this because from the minority
position we've been working hard and now
we need to help to help this president
help any future president or any
political opponent not have the FISA
Court abusing their rights so it sounds
like you don't have the votes to clear a
clean FISA next week no I don't think we
do and I think that's a good thing I
think that's good for the president I
think it's good for the country because
how many times have you and I talked
about yeah the fact that people have
lost trust in the Department of just a
lost trust in the FISA Court and
remember the FISA Court was put into
place from the cévennes late in the 70s
because of abuses in the intelligence
system and in visas among law
enforcement does that not sound familiar
today it's worth reevaluating then we
need to reevaluate now well you're right
and we keep talking about it I've been
talking about it with Lindsey Graham is
round now senator Graham has started
interviews I guess but is it too late
you know too little too late I mean are
we gonna actually get a capped ability
my audience wants accountability and so
far we haven't seen many interviews you
know subpoenas from Lindsey Graham well
I'd like to see more and I think that's
the thing we've been pushing for for the
last year in the house we've been at the
tip of the spear we've called sham
impeachment we fought Muller I mean we
have done this all that and so I'm
hopeful that with the majority in the
Senate they're gonna continue that I'm
glad to see that they finally got
started and I'd love to see more of that
it was amazing this past week when Ron
Johnson was actually the American
senator Johnson was trying to actually
do something
they were Mitt Romney all of a sudden
decided he was going to possibly object
to subpoenas we've got to get over this
this happened in abuse of our system and
it is something that goes back to the
very integral part of what the DOJ does
especially when it comes to political
folks and when they attack president
Trump when they attack then Canada Trump
and tried to cover it up and use FISA
there's nobody in this country that
could be immune from that kind of abuse
yeah I'm glad you mentioned Senator
Romney I'm gonna talk about that with
Kevin McCarthy coming up
GOP Minority Leader a congressman throws
as a pleasure to see you sir thanks so
much good to see Matt Collins joining us
there